better the company that owns both
Facebook and Instagram even tried to
make the platform safer I've been
speaking to Dex Hunter toric of the
oversight board which tries to keep meta
and its boss Mark Zuckerberg in check
thanks thanks for coming on the show
great to be here um first of all can we
talk about you and your background
um can you give our viewers an idea of
which big companies you've worked at and
what you're doing now uh sure I mean I
started my career at the UN actually as
a policy guy and I made the transition
of its working in Silicon Valley after a
couple of years in a very large
impenetrable bureaucracy I thought I
want to go work with folks who are
trying to change the world and maybe do
it in a little faster paced way so I
ended up at Google after that I was at
Facebook and then I went to work for
Elon Musk at SpaceX and I've been in
Communications and public policy for
about 15 years and I'm now at a body
called the oversight board which is a
independent body that was originally
created by meta in 2020 and we operate
as an independent Watchdog essentially
which looks at some of the controversial
content issues on Facebook and Instagram
So Meta owns Facebook and it owns
Instagram two of the world's biggest uh
platforms what sort of oversight do you
perform what do you actually do yeah so
there are billions of people using
Facebook and Instagram and every day a
lot of people are seeing their content
moderated by the company so you may post
something that's then taken down by the
company you may see something on the
platform which you want to see removed
and which you think violates the rules
which might harm users these are issues
which you can appeal to the company but
if you don't get satisfaction from meta
you can then appeal them to the
oversight board and an independent body
a set of members we've got 23 uh folks
from around the world they make
decisions then about whether that
content should be removed or restored
from the platform and we also make
recommendations on how to fix meta
systems and and that's for many people
watching this interview especially those
perhaps with children I've got to myself
one is on social media one's a little
bit too little yet to do that
there is for some parents a sort of
feeling of helplessness about keeping
your kids safe from the toxic effects of
social media do you accept that for many
people social media has been a negative
and many of them feel utterly powerless
to sort of control that environment or
keep their children safe you see that
that is a problem absolutely I mean I
think there are a lot of people who are
very very concerned about how to you
know protect their children online and
every day there are people facing all
sorts of horrendous abuse of course
social media also has huge positives um
you know I think we often take it for
granted uh in Western Democratic
countries you know the value that having
access to speech um you know being able
to communicate in this scale can have
for people
um but absolutely there are problems
we've got to deal with them otherwise we
will lose the promise of social media
and in terms of sort of concerns there
was also the issue of Donald Trump and
uh he's now been reinstated on Facebook
and Instagram that was metta's decision
I was under the oversight board wasn't
involved in that decision that's not
that's not something that the board
would get involved with so we did
actually have a role um so in 2021 of
course uh Donald Trump was suspended
from Facebook and Instagram after the
events of January 6. and uh the company
subsequently asked the board to decide
was that suspension correct and the
board made a decision there we actually
said although it was right that uh
president Trump had been suspended it
was an indefinite suspension and that
was wrong it was a penalty that wasn't
actually contained in meta's rules they
basically invented this penalty with no
criteria for when they imposed it or
lifted it so we told the company the
process you used to impose these kinds
of penalties is as important as the
decision and we sent it back to the
company they subsequently imposed a
two-year suspension which um they've
just announced is being lifted okay so
you said regardless of the rights of
wrong of the case you can't just be your
own arbiter is you have to have a
process that's right it's been now weeks
after the John 6 house committee report
concluded that that Trump directed
encourage and supports an attempt to
overthrow American democracy matter
though then concluded after this
two-year time
threshold that the risk to Public Safety
have diminished when it comes to Trump
and that's just as he launches a new bid
for presidency you had nothing to say
about this as the board why so from the
board side we don't want to speak about
this currently because we may end up
jeopardizing a future decision if this
comes back to the board so this is
actually for us a question of remaining
neutral and impartial before we
potentially have to deal with this in
the future so what's the trigger for a
further suspension yeah I mean I think
it would be if there's a future Grievous
breach of the rules that are designed to
protect users on the platform it's the
house report includes more than 50
references to Facebook highlighting how
his Trump and his followers spread false
claims shared them encouraged people to
head to DC to stop the steel and used
often Facebook you'll know this to do it
how troubled are the oversight board
about the house accusing Facebook and
other social media companies of
amplifying lies and radicalizing that's
to quote quote the house report the
House of Representative support
radicalizing consumers uh we are
absolutely concerned about that and
actually the board has previously uh
told the company that they should commit
to an independent investigation of any
role that the company's platforms may
have played in amplifying that kind of
content we of course said it was right
to suspend Donald Trump in 2021 so this
is something that we're going to
continue focusing on very very carefully
and what did they say when you
recommended an independent investment
they actually didn't commit to that but
they did commit to talking to external
researchers and working with them to be
concerned about it it's quite toothless
isn't it if you recommend an independent
investigation into what happened because
it was potentially egregious breach of
rules with with profound consequences
and then let's just ignore you I mean it
makes you a bit of a toothless board
doesn't it I don't think so I mean you
see you see the point I think you could
absolutely make that argument but I I
don't think it's quite right there's a
there's another sort of layer to this
because the Whistleblower Francis uh
Hogan came forward in 21 with the
troubling account of what happened
around Jones Street she said Facebook
understood the danger of the 2020
election turned on Safety Systems to
reduce misinformation which they called
Civic integrity and as soon as the
election was over turned them back off
we'll change the setting back to what
they were before to prioritize what she
described as growth over safety and that
was the environment in which Facebook
played a key role in the events of John
VI that's quite a betrayal of democracy
isn't it I think you could absolutely
make that argument so Francis Haugen I
think she had a very important role to
play in demanding transparency from the
company from the board side we spoke to
Francis howgan a couple of times we
certainly found the site she provided
incredibly helpful and it actually
guided how we investigated the company
to just come on to something else it's
not just about sort of democracy and
politics if we come on to children to
quote Francis again she also taught
about the price being paid potentially
by young people and she brought to light
internal and studies from inside much
that revealed that 13.5 percent of teen
girls say Instagram makes thoughts of
suicide worse and 17 of teen girls that
say Instagram makes Eating Disorders
worse
that's that's unacceptable isn't it
absolutely and this is an area which the
company should absolutely be committing
to work much more closely with
researchers it's something which
regulators and governments also need to
be taking a firm stand on so what would
you like to see Dax I mean you're an
expert in this field what do you think
they could do to actually affect change
because I'm sure people watching this
with teenagers like my own
think well what could the companies
actually do to to make this a more
positive environment for their young
people who you can't get off these
websites to be honest you can't get them
off the social media sites even if you
want to yeah sure unless you put them in
a cave just lock them up take away all
their technology well there's a concept
that we have been talking about in the
tech industry and in conversations with
policy makers for many years around the
concept of media literacy and how people
should actually be navigating through
online spaces which present all sorts of
harms and
um certainly I have never seen any
example anywhere in the world of
effective media literacy programs being
rolled out at scale it's something where
frankly governments need to you know up
their game as well but it's something
where companies should be made to commit
resources to it's a dangerous new world
out there we need to raise young people
to be prepared to navigate these spaces
Hogan sums up she says Facebook's
realize that if they change the
algorithm to be safe for people spend
less time on the site they'll click on
less ads they'll make less money is that
is that right I'm not sure that's true
um you know actually when you have
environments which are harmful to people
which promote polarization which promote
harms um lots of people will get
disengaged consumers aren't buying to
this stuff
um
and just just just to finish off on on
this and some of the stuff that Francis
Haugen said
um there was the case of Molly Russell
which you will know she consumed content
on sites including Instagram that
focused on self-harm and suicide she
took her own life at the age of 14. how
troubled
Were You by that being in this space and
the ill effects it had on this
particular young person I don't think
anybody with a conscience or a soul
could not be troubled by this it was
obviously something that revealed a
terribly evil type of content out there
and also a failure of the systems that
were used by the company there so it's
absolutely something which I think
should be a wake-up call uh to
governments as well as the tech industry
on why we need to move faster and Dex
What did the what have the tax industry
done about it so I understand one of the
big things in the Online safety bill is
actually outlawing an entire content of
self-harm content it's also something
where we understand meta has put in new
restrictions as well and they've beefed
up enforcement there but I think the
proof's going to be in the pudding does
it actually stop young people
self-harming does it remove that content
and would you like to see media literacy
in the perhaps in the online harmful but
would you like to see that legislated
for I would absolutely absolutely it's
something that I think should be an
urgent priority for us and of course we
know the next generation of Technology
tools like AI things like the metaverse
they're going to present all sorts of
issues as well would you be in for
technology companies funding those sorts
of programs I think if your business
model relies on uh connecting a lot of
consumers and you're making a lot of
money from that you have an obligation
to invest in the uh protections for
those users as well so you could you
wouldn't you you could see a sort of a
specific tax for something like that
potentially I think it's something we
should certainly investigate just on
keeping young people safe I have to
bring up Andrew Tate his violent
misogyny finding its way onto computers
and phones of boys across the world I
have a teenage boy he and all of his
friends seem to know about Andrew Tate I
don't know how it has somehow uh gone
into the consciousness of these young
men but it has it has met and maintain a
ban on him but your former boss Elon
Musk has a loud Tate to spread his
poison on Twitter you know mask
is he fit to run a social media platform
I think we'll have to wait and see how
Twitter evolves over the coming months
and years um certainly I think lots of
people including myself are very very
concerned at some of the unpredictable
changes that have happened to the
platform that's you've you've worked for
Elon Musk you know well you've worked
for Mark Zuckerberg you know him well do
you think email us as a character is
someone that should have a huge social
media platform I mean he's somebody who
obviously feels very passionate about
freedom of expression at the same time
he's somebody who's got his own very
strong point of view and uh social media
is if nothing else about managing very
diverse communities with a lot of
interest which you are chilon must to
take Tate off Twitter I would yes
so you think you should take Tate of
Twitter and and what about other
companies such as Facebook and Instagram
should they be doing more to stop the
sharing of taped material on their
platforms yeah I mean um
there is content that is incredibly
harmful I think we need to look at our
case-by-case basis but certainly where
there is a record there's a track record
well built up of incredibly harmful
things being applied to a whole
generation of people um we need to take
action we can't just be talking about it
what why would you like to see him taken
off though Tate I mean it's uh exactly
as you pointed out Beth there's a person
here who has been spreading incredibly
uh terrible misogynistic harmful content
to lots of people
um and these are the sorts of online
harms that I think uh there is a very
strong consensus in society including
the policy makers and the tech industry
that we need to take more action on
so you think it should be joined up with
government and the company's policy
makers absolutely need to work with the
tech industry uh these are problems that
we can't simply ask the tech industry to
solve on their own we need leadership as
well from politicians Dex thank you so
much
um for giving me your time it's a very
fascinating conversation I appreciate it
thanks Beth thank you
Alexi navalny has never been afraid to
stand up to Vladimir Putin but the
Russian opposition leaders activism has
come into huge personal cost over the
last decade he has been attacked and
detained in 2020 he was poisoned with
the same nerve agent used in the
Salisbury poisonings miraculously he
survived but only thanks to the
treatment he received in a German
Hospital on return to Russia he was
jailed on charges he says were
politically motivated the European Court
of human rights has agreed demanding his
release but today he remains
incarcerated
now a documentary about Alexi navarney's
attempt to find out who poisoned him is
nominated for an Oscar and a bafta I've
been speaking to its director Daniel
rule about the impact of the film and
what we know now about Alexi navalny's
current condition
Daniel thank you for coming on the show
now your documentary about navani is
gripping it's moving it's quite an
extraordinary piece of work and
extraordinary
story but fast can you explain to our
viewers where Alexi navarney is being
held what sort of facility he's in and
what shape he's in well first and
foremost thank you so much for having me
on the program it's great to be with you
here today and any opportunity to talk
about navalny is very meaningful for me
because the sad reality is that he's not
doing well unfortunately our film does
not have a happy ending right now
navalny is languishing in a penal colony
about six and a half hours outside of
Moscow he has been for most of the last
six months removed from the general
prison population and is instead
languishing in solitary confinement and
he is being held in what many
International observers will will say is
torturous conditions you know they it's
as if these these prison authorities
wake up every morning and and ask
themselves how they can make this guy's
life miserable and it's important that
your viewers know the reason he's
specifically in solitary confinement
this is very important is because of his
anti-war advocacy Alexey navalny is the
number one anti-war advocate in Russia
Today and that's why he's in solitary
confinement languishing do you think
that the start of the Ukraine war
intensified the brutality against
navalny
by the Russian authorities because of
this right I think the start of the
Ukraine war intensified the pressure not
just of only but all oppositionists all
uh uh political people with different
opinions all independent news outlets
navalny is one man but he seems to
represent hundreds if not thousands of
of uh independent Russians who have had
to sacrifice a great deal in opposition
of this war and Daniel
Nevada's supporters believe his life is
in grave danger right now how worried
are you about
whether he can survive
I'm extraordinarily worried it's it's
very scary you know he is in the custody
of the same man who tried to murder him
once what's stopping them from trying
again
it's it's
urgent it's vital the world needs to pay
attention to navalny we cannot forget
him that's how I frame the primary
responsibility of our documentary is to
provide the world with with a a vehicle
to get to know him and to learn about
his story there's also The Bravery of
his family who feature very heavily his
two children and his wife Yulia in the
documentary and they clearly are very
tight
loving family
um how are they bearing up do you
you presumed her in contact with the
family they must be missing their Dad
terribly I I think that
the the Dignity of Yulia navalny is such
that she keeps her cards pretty close to
her chest I think it's a Russian thing
but you can only imagine what it must be
like if your husband if your father is
in this horrible position this horrible
place you know he's not doing well you
know that he's being tortured that must
be
a burden that I can't even imagine that
certainly no College age or or high
school age students should have to
endure
um but the family like their father
has this remarkable courage when you
release the film and livoni was
imprisoned again did you fear the
consequences it release might have for
him or did you hope
that this amplification
of his story might actually give him
better protection or were you just not
sure
well
the film premiered three weeks before
this awful horrendous war in Ukraine
started and I think when the When The
War Began everyone was existing in this
ocean of uncertainty what's going to
happen What would stop these lunatics
from murdering navalny as they are
raining bombs down on this country in
Central Europe on Ukraine and so we
thought that we had to do we had a
responsibility to do whatever we could
to try and keep navani's name in the
global Consciousness as a mechanism to
dissuade the regime from murdering him
and so we had this very fancy film
release plan you know films are released
at a very specific time there's lots of
planning that goes into their rollout
and their promotion we threw it all away
and instead we embarked on a uh
expedited get this film out into the
world as quickly as possible Mission and
the potential consequences of which we
were not concerned about What mattered
most to us was the security and safety
of navalny and if this film can move the
dial five or ten percent in dissuading
the regime for murdering him we
understood we had a responsibility to
get it out I guess the question of his
followers from that donors if they tried
to murder him once I and now they have
him incarcerated why weren't they trying
to murder him again I think it's a it's
a it's a very fair question and that's
why I think navalny is in a very very
scary position my working calculus
um I call it the the pain in the ass
index
they're sort of like is it more of a
pain in the ass for for the regime to
murder him or to instead let him
languish and what that speaks to is what
would the domestic response be how many
hundreds of thousands of people would
take to the streets would that
potentially be the straw that breaks the
camel's back and gets people engaged
gets people out into the streets and I
think the regime doesn't want to figure
that out so instead they say we'll let
him live but we will break his Spirit we
will break his body we will break his
well-being and we will let him languish
in this cell I would prefer of course
that he is freed and that he is reunited
with his family but more than anything
we just need him to survive this because
it's my opinion that his impact on the
future of Russia is unfulfilled and I
would like to see the day when he is
able to run in a free and fair
democratic election in the Russian
Federation and Daniel
arguably the most gripping part of the
film
is when
navalny with the help of Christo is able
to identify suspects behind his
poisoning yeah and they find telephone
numbers I mean it's an incredible it's
hardly believable right it's so
extraordinary but you know they
essentially prank them these guys by
pretending to be aids to FSB agents and
get information about his poisoning and
you can't actually quite believe that
someone is just over the telephone
handing over this information can you
explain what happened on that day and
what you were thinking
when you are capturing that sure navalny
started the day
um just trying just as himself he'd get
a guy on the phone he'd say this is
navalny why'd you try and murder me and
then they'd hang up and it was not a
successful attempt and then at a certain
point someone decided I think Maria
suggested let's try it the prank way the
backup option where navalny would try
and impersonate a high-ranking FSB guy
and see if he could fool someone which
sounded as Outland just outlandish to me
then as it does now but they made the
first call then they made the second
call and the third call they called up
this chemist called Constantine
contrativ and I don't speak a word of
Russian so I'm just trying to
intuitively figure out where to put the
camera but once they got this guy on the
phone I sort of clocked out of the
corner of my eye as Maria pevchik yeah
navali's Chief investigator I saw her
jaw unhinged and hit the floor and I
understood that something extraordinary
was happening and you didn't have to
speak a word of Russian to know exactly
what was going down yeah
[Music]
generation
um
[Music]
foreign
they're going to kill him when they when
we put this out what happened to him you
don't know well it's unclear we thought
for a while that he was dead we thought
that he had been disappeared yeah it
came into Focus about a year ago I think
Christo dug up uh a covid database a
database of covid tests and his name was
on it somewhere in Siberia so we think
he's alive but perhaps he has been
relegated to some terrible desk job in
the remote regions of Russia for this
horrible indiscretion he perpetrated
right at the end of the film you ask him
what is the message to the Russian
people
if their prison you will kill you
and he answers the question about if
they kill me this is the message and
you're asking him to do it in Russian
yeah and it's the way into film and he
says the only thing necessary for the
Triumph of evil is for good people to do
nothing so don't do nothing
the question I had as a viewer
afterwards was what was his answer about
if he was imprisoned because that became
his reality they didn't kill him but
they imprisoned him what did he answer
on that question well I don't remember
verbatim and had to look at the
transcripts
um but I would imagine that it was in a
very similar vein do not give up do not
look down he said something very
poignant we cannot look down we have to
look up and we have to we have to tackle
this thing head on these bad guys are
only able to exist if good people do
nothing so don't be inactive and that is
not just a call to Russian citizens
that's to call the Citizens all over the
world over the last 10 15 20 years we
have seen the rise of authoritarianism
take different Insidious forms and
proliferate to different pockets and
corners of the world that we thought
were immune to this type of this type of
instinct and what navalny is saying
doesn't just apply to Russia it applies
to to citizens all over the world
as his friend and as someone that has
worked with him and knows him well on a
personal level do you wish he hadn't
gone back given what's happened because
that's how I ended the film I thought
don't go back
you know it's challenging to say first
off
I always wonder if his calculus would
have been different if he had a crystal
ball and knew that this war this
horrendous war was going to begin would
he have still gone back in that context
but the reality is we had no idea he he
had the information he had and he made
the decision he made it was a political
decision I think if you were here right
now what he might suggest is that
staying out of the country staying in
Exile would be too great a gift to the
Kremlin so he had to go back he wants to
be the moral leader of the nation and
and unfortunately for him that meant I'm
not sacrificing himself in this way
thanks for coming in and certainly the
film has Amplified historian and and you
have managed to get it nominated in the
the biggest theater yeah in the world
which can only be good good for him as
well so thank you so much for coming in
and talking to us about welcome thank
you so much for having me my I'm I'm sad
that Alexei navalny won't get to go to
the baftas or the Oscars but he's with
us in spirit and any chance to talk
about the film is Meaningful so thank
you Pat thank you thanks so much
appreciate it
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversation so I found both of them
absolutely fascinating now if you scan
this QR code on your screen now you can
watch all of our interviews online and
all the previous episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to Beth
Rigby interviews our podcast that's on
the Sky News app or wherever you get
your podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much to my guest Daniel raw and
Dex Hunter torik and thank you for
watching hope to see you next week
foreign
[Music]